HAVE A GREAT NIGHT,
EVERYBODY.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE SAT HOW MUCH YOU KNEW
ABOUT ACADEMIC SUBJECTS
ENGLISH AND MATH.
THE NEW WOKE PRIVILEGE.
WANT TO GET YOUR KIDS INTO
HARVARD GET DIVORCED AND
MOVE TO A BAD NEIGHBORHOOD.
MORE ON THAT STORY IN A
MINUTE.
FIRST TONIGHT IF A MAN RUNS
FOR PRESIDENT BUT NOBODY
SUPPORTS HIM, IS IT REALLY A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN?
THAT'S A PHILOSOPHICAL
QUESTION OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S ALSO SUDSENLY A VERY
PRACTICAL CONCERN FOR BILL
DE BLASIO THE MAYOR OF NEW
YORK.
THE MAYOR ANNOUNCED TODAY
AFTER YEARS OF DESTROYING
THE NATION'S LARGEST CITY HE
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO DO
THE SAME THING TO AMERICA.
WATCH.
>> THERE IS PLENTY OF MONEY
IN THIS WORLD.
THERE IS PLENTY OF MONEY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S JUST IN THE WRONG
HANDS.
I'M IN A NEW YORKER.
I HAVE KNOWN TRUMP'S A BULLY
FOR A LONG TIME.
THIS IS NOT NEWS TO ME OR
ANYONE ELSE HERE.
I KNOW HOW TO TAKE HIM ON.
DONALD TRUMP MUST BE
STOPPED.
I'VE BEATEN HIM BEFORE AND I
WILL DO IT AGAIN.
I'M BILL DE BLASIO AND I'M
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
BECAUSE IT'S TIME WE PUT
WORKING PEOPLE FIRST.
>> Tucker: SPOILER ALERT
BILL DE BLASIO IS NEVER
GOING TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE IS DUMB.
IS HE UNPOPULAR.
IS HE ALMOST COMICALLY
INCOMPETENT.
IS HE EXACTLY THE KIND OF
PERSON WHO SHOULD NOT BE
SMOKING A LOT OF MARIJUANA
BUT APPARENTLY IS ANYWAY.
THAT'S BILL DE BLASIO.
THE GOOD NEWS IS HE IS ALSO
KIND OF ENTERTAINING IF YOU
DON'T HAVE TO LIVE IN HIS
CITY.
WHILE WE STILL CAN SIT BACK
AND ENJOY THE BUFFOONERY.
THERE IS A LOT OF IT.
HE BEGAN TODAY WITH HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT VIDEO IN WHICH
DE BLASIO PLEDGED TO FIGHT
FOR WORKING PEOPLE WHILE
BEING DRIVEN BY A CHAUFFEUR
AROUND THE STREETS OF NEW
YORK.
EVEN CNN WHICH HAS BEEN
HAPPY TO PROMOTE TRANSPARENT
PHONIES LIKE KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND AND PETE
BUTTIGIEG WAS NOT IMPRESSED.
>> THERE IS A PALPABLE LACK
OF EXCITEMENT IN THE STREETS
OF NEW YORK.
THREE QUARTERS OF NEW
YORKERS DON'T WANT HIM TO
RUN.
ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS WITH
BILL DE BLASIO HE IS NOT
SHOWING UP TO WORK.
HE DOESN'T COME IN AT ALL HE
COMES IN LATE.
DISINTERESTED IN RUNNING THE
AMERICA'S LARGEST BIG CITY.
UNDER WATER OFTEN IN THE
POLLS A CITY 6 TO 1
DEMOCRAT.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY FRIENDS
EXCITED ABOUT BILL DE BLASIO
FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU ARE
BILL DE BLASIO, THIS HAS GOT
TO HURT, STINGS, CNN WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A CRITICAL
ALLY IN THIS RACE.
UNFORTUNATELY CNN IS BASED
IN NEW YORK CITY AND THAT
MEANS IT'S EMPLOYEES KNOW
EXACTLY HOW INCOMPETENT AT
THE PRESENT TIME THEIR MAYOR
IS THEY HAVE TO WEIGHED
THROUGH PILE OF GARBAGE TO
GET TO WORK EVERY MORNING.
NBC IS IN NEW YORK TOO.
CAN YOU TELL THE WAY THEY
COVERED HIS ANNOUNCEMENT,
WATCH.
>> HE IS NOT WHAT ANYONE
WOULD CALL POPULAR BACK IN
NEW YORK.
>> LAST MONTH IN A
QUINNIPIAC POLL 76% OF NEW
YORKERS SAID HE SHOULD NOT
RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
MAYOR DE BLASIO SAYING IS HE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I FEEL LIKE HE HAS A LOT OF
STUFF TO DO IN NEW YORK
CITY, FIRST.
>> I'M NOT ENCOURAGED BY HIS
POLICIES IN THE CITY.
>> ABOUT TIME A WOMAN RUN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> HE SHOULD ANNOUNCE ON THE
FIRST OF APRIL.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD
APRIL FOOL'S DAY JOKE.
>> Tucker: OUCH.
AT THIS POINT IF YOU
PERSONALLY ARE EXCITED FOR
BILL DE BLASIO PRESIDENCY,
PLEASE LET HIS CAMPAIGN
KNOW.
YOU ARE LIKELY QUALIFIED FOR
A PAID STAFF POSITION.
SO OBVIOUSLY DOOMED EVERYONE
KNOWS IT INCLUDING YOU WOULD
THINK MS. DE BLASIO.
WHY IS DE BLASIO RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THE SAME REASON HE RAN FOR
NEW YORK.
NARCISSISM.
SMUG, ARROGANT, UTTERLY
HYPOCRITICAL AND LACKING IN
SELF-AWARENESS.
THIS IS THE MAN WHO
ANNOUNCED HIS OWN GREEN DEAL
BUT THEN TOOK A HELICOPTER
TO THE GYM.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SENT COPS
INTO THE SUBWAY TO SHOE
HOMELESS PEOPLE OUT OF THE
WAY BEFORE HE RIDES IT BUT
LET'S THE CITY DROWN IN
CRASH.
HE DEMANDS YOU STOP EATING
HOT DOGS BECAUSE THEY ARE
BAD BUT THEN PROMOTES
SMOKING WEED.
DE BLASIO ONLY PERSON IN NEW
YORK WHO HAS NO IDEA WHAT AN
IDIOT DE BLASIO IS.
TOTALLY MEDIOCRE AND
COMPLETELY SELF-CONFIDENT.
AMAZING COMBINATION.
LESS RARE THAN YOU WOULD